well the warship moskva the flagship of
the russian black sea fleet has been
badly damaged after an explosion the
russian defense ministry said a fire
caused ammunition to detonate it didn't
say what caused the blaze but did say
the entire crew of 500 sailors had been
evacuated however ukrainian officials
claim two of their missiles hit the ship
i'm now joined by military analyst and
former general in the uk armed forces
chris deverell chris thank you for
joining us here on dw and first of all i
want to talk about the russian black sea
fleet flagship moskva russia admits it
caught fire but says it was an
ammunition explosion an accident we'll
say ukraine says it struck the moskva
with two missiles what do you think is
more likely
well actually both could be true i it
could be the case that ukrainian missile
structure ship which caused an
ammunition explosion
and that's a distinct possibility
i i think that
the evidences that ukrainians
did take into service with the ukrainian
navy last year
um an upgraded ex-soviet missile called
neptune maximum range about 200 miles
which is about halfway across the black
sea they have demonstrated their ability
to hit russian ships before destroying
um a landing support vessel the orsk
in the port of berliensk near mariopol
in in the sea of azov
fairly recently so i i suspect the
answer is is indeed
the case that the moskva has been sunk
or is badly damaged by by ukrainian
missiles
now russia is also saying ukrainian
forces defending marijuana have
surrendered on mass now if mariupol has
fallen how serious a blow is that to
ukraine's defense of the country
i think firstly i don't think we know
that it has fallen i mean
that the russians are reporting
large-scale surrenders but the
ukrainians haven't confirmed that and
they say that fighting is still ongoing
i think the evidence is it's a matter of
time uh before eventually maripo falls
uh because the russians have
overwhelming
superiority numbers there and and and
the appearance is surrounded
uh and i think the most likely thing
that that would result in is the freeing
up of those troops to go north um
to
assist the
russian campaign and the donbas
an alternative is that they would go in
the opposite direction towards odessa
but i think it's now looking as if the
russians have given up on on trying to
take odessa
well are the mil ukrainian forces
prepared um in the east and and
southeast of the country
they've been there a long time you know
there have been ukrainian forces in that
area since
the russians invaded the donbas and took
crimea in 2014. so
so they've been there a long time they
will dug in
they're
well equipped or certainly increasingly
well equipped by
by western uh munitions and and
um
and so
you know i think
it's a significant proportion of the
ukrainian army i guess about just under
half uh is in that area so i think it
it's not an easy thing to do for the
russians to
uh
overcome them
the russian armed forces would have to
get considerably more effective
to do so uh
you know i don't think they're going to
succeed even with their more
limited objectives what they can do is a
lot of damage to ukrainian
infrastructure and kill a lot of
civilians
do you think we're going to see an
escalation in the level of force that
the russian military is prepared to use
yes
i think certainly in terms of artillery
munitions and missiles
friends will fire an enormous amount of
ordnance
uh against the ukrainians not just the
military but against the cities which
will which will destroy them and and
kill civilians
so so yes i think the the volume of
uh
of munitions fired by the russians is
going to increase and and uh
it's it's going to be horrible
military analyst and former british army
general chris deveral thank you
thank you pablo
earlier we spoke with dr aglais netkoff
from london she is a lecturer in
international politics at university
college london school of slavonic and
east european studies she explained the
potential importance of what happened to
the warship
i think it's significant that the
russians have admitted there is a fire
on board
and that they've had to evacuate i think
that's significant whether or not it was
hit by
the ukrainian missiles most likely it
was but at this stage we cannot
independently verify i think
symbolically it is huge
my sky is a major warship um
it was it was most notably involved in
the sort of snake island incident the
stamps of which have actually uh only
come out this week
in ukrainian
in ukraine
symbolically it's massive it will also
be important strategically militarily
because the russians are no longer able
to move their large warships into the
area because the straits have been shut
down and also because it shows that um
the russians are
suffer ongoing suffering heavy losses
which i think before the campaign in
dambass is renewed i think it's you know
it's symbolically important that the
russians are suffering such heavy losses
even before their campaign in dambassa
sort of you know is stepped up again
um
i think there's also a question of how
long can the russians continue to suffer
such sort of heavy losses because um
such warships are sort of very expensive
very difficult to produce there's not
many of them around
that was dr aglais netkov a lecturer in
international politics at university
college london school of slavonic and
east european studies